[Musik]
eine kehrtwende und eine entschuldigung
die kanzlerin streicht die ruhetage an
gründonnerstag und karsamstag weniger
einkaufsstress zu ostern erleichterung
bei der wirtschaft aber die zweifel am
corona management wachsen und verwirrung
um astrazeneca impfstoff in einem
italienischen werk entdecken eu
kontrolleure fast 30 millionen dosen
aber für wen sind sie bestimmt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg ein denkwürdiger
nachrichten tag schön dass ihr dabei
sind wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sport als wunderanzug von mir
das gab es so wohl noch nie mitten in
der krise gesteht die bundeskanzlerin
einen persönlichen fehler ein korrigiert
ihn und bittet um entschuldigung
die einen sollen ihr dafür respekt
andere fordern angela merkel auf die
vertrauensfrage zu stellen
dazu gleich mehr jetzt zeigen wir ihnen
erst mal die wichtigsten passagen von
merkels vier minuten auftritt ich habe
mich zu diesem kurzen pressetermin
entschlossen weil ich heute vormittag
entschieden habe die notwendigen
verordnungen für die am montag
vereinbarte zusätzliche oster ruhe also
die ruhetage am gründonnerstag und
karsamstag nicht auf den weg zu bringen
sondern sie zu stoppen
denn am ende trage ich für alles die
letzte verantwortung qua amt ist das so
also auch für die am montag getroffene
entscheidung zur sogenannten oster ruhe
ein fehler muss als fehler genannt
werden und vor allem muss er korrigiert
werden und ermöglicht hat dass noch
rechtzeitig zu geschehen
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung ausgelöst
das bedauere ich zutiefst und dafür
bitte ich alle bürgerinnen und bürger um
verzeihung
soweit die kanzlerin aber wie kam es
überhaupt dazu rückblick erst die c
video konferenz von bund und ländern
vorgestern am abend stunden lange
unterbrechung und dann der überraschende
beschluss wir setzen auf ostern ruhetage
am morgen danach reibt sich deutschland
verblüfft die augen und heute gleich
nochmal
denn gut 24 stunden nach der
entscheidung heißt es kommando zurück
die herrscher über merkels fehler und
die folgen das kabinett der
bundesregierung geht am morgen gerade in
berlin zu ende
in den ländern wollen die
ministerpräsidentinnen die korona
beschlüsse in regierungserklärungen
verteidigen
doch es kommt anders diese
ministerpräsident & friends hat die
menschen enttäuscht
wir können so nicht weitermachen das ist
das was ich irgendwie heute über mittel
ich werde deshalb heute ich werde heute
ich werde heute jetzt gleich die debatte
wieder verlassen müssen weil die
bundeskanzlerin heute für 11 uhr die
ministerpräsidenten erneut kurzfristig
von zehn minuten eingeladen hat und ich
denke dass wir sehr kritisch doch über
das reden was da vor zwei tagen passiert
ist
nach dieser telefonschalte noch ein
ungewöhnlicher schritt
angela merkel tippt die entscheidung zur
sogenannten oster ruhe und spricht in
einem vier minuten auftritt von eigenen
fehlern bedauern und bittet um
verzeihung und es klipp und klar zu
sagen die idee eines oster shutdown zwar
mit bester absicht entworfen worden
denn wir müssen es unbedingt schaffen
die dritte welle der pandemie zu bremsen
und umzukehren
dennoch war die idee der sogenannten
oster ruhe ein fehler
dieser fehler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler
damit nimmt angela merkel ihrem
kanzleramtschef aus dem fokus der die
idee von der oster uhr hatte eine idee
die 16 länder vorgestern nacht
mitgetragen haben gemeldet bekommen aber
solch einen sturm habe ich ihn gefragt
noch nicht erleben
dieser beschluss war insofern ein fehler
den wir alle gemeinsam die
bundeskanzlerin alle
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten gemacht haben ich
trage die verantwortung denn tatsächlich
zu der oster hohe tragen 16
ministerpräsidentin und die
bundeskanzlerin die verantwortung
sie ist zwar nichts tatsächlich passiert
aber natürlich gibt es ein vertrauen
schaffen und es tut uns leid es tut auch
mir leid
in berlin wird angela merkel von der
opposition aufgefordert die
vertrauensfrage zu stellen
das lehnt sie ab theo koll in berlin wie
groß ist der schaden der
vertrauensverlust nach dieser rolle
rückwärts aus dem öffentlichen hin und
her und der verwirrung hat dieses
politische ostereier bisher kaum
konkreten schaden angerichtet aber
dieser fehler kommt wie viele kommt zu
vielen anderen obendrauf und weil
diesmal das versagen so klar erkennbar
ist hat es schnell auch all die anderen
kritischen punkte der pandemie politik
im schlepptau und beschädigt damit
deutlich vertrauen und geduld der
menschen die kanzlerin ist in den
letzten monaten ihrer politischen
abendsonne und erfahrungsgemäß ist das
eine zeit abnehmender autorität und auch
schwindendem schutz vor kritik und mit
einer solchen schlappe machte es angela
merkel ihren kritikern jetzt deutlich
leichter fiele es bei ihr abzuladen
die angeordnete osterholz vom tisch was
ist jetzt der plan b gegen die soester
ruhe war ja eigentlich schon der plan b
den ursprünglich wollte die
bundesregierung nächtliche
ausgangssperren dänen hatten sich aber
die anderen ja wieder setzt jetzt gelten
zumindest noch alle anderen beschlüsse
vom von montagnacht und die regierung
lässt aktuell von justiz und
innenministerium prüfen ob sie
auslandsreisen in beliebte urlaubsziele
verbieten kann es ist allen dabei klar
dass für ein solches verbot hohe
verfassungsrechtliche hürden bestehen
und nach der gescheiterten oster ruhe
würde man natürlich einen zweiten fehler
vermeiden dennoch hat die regierung das
erklärte ziel solcher reisen
vorübergehend zu unterbinden ähnlich wie
es ja auch schon die briten machen dort
sind touristische oder private reisen
ins ausland bis mitte mai schlichtweg
verboten informationen live aus berlin
von theo koll dankeschön um 12 uhr 30
bittet die kanzlerin vor der presse um
entschuldigung eine halbe stunde später
stellt sie sich im bundestag den fragen
der abgeordneten
die üben massive kritik am
missmanagement in der krise aber vor
allem auch an der entscheidungsrunde aus
kanzlerin und ministerpräsidenten
während beim team berichtet erst
treffen mit den mps dann die
pressekonferenz und jetzt kurz danach
muss die kanzlerin den abgeordneten rede
und antwort stehen
viel anerkennung gibt es für die
entschuldigung viel kritik weil der
bundestag zu oft zum zuschauen verdammt
sei wann hören sie endlich auf zu
versuchen hinter verschlossenen türen im
ganz kleinen kreise mitten in der nacht
über das leben von millionen von
menschen zu entscheiden wann legen sie
die entscheidung zurück in die hände der
parlamente also ich würde schon mal
sagen dass so wie hier im parlament
sachverstand ist auch in der
bundesregierung sachverstand ist bei den
ministerpräsidenten sachverstand ist und
über die verbesserung der arbeitsweise
das haben wir uns heute in der runde
auch gesagt müssen wir noch einmal
werden wir auch noch einmal miteinander
reden
viele nutzen ihre fragen für forderungen
eine kabinettsumbildung lehnt merkel ab
das stellen der vertrauensfrage
auch und auch der sozialdemokratischen
fraktion haben wollen sie da merkel
verteidigt die art und weise der
entscheidungen eine alternative zur bund
länder runde sieht sie nicht
warum weigern sie sich bis heute einen
stufenplan hier im parlament zu
verabschieden wenn da steht das bei
institution über 50 umfassende maßnahmen
zu ergreifen sind
dann sagen die länder welche umfassende
maßnahmen für meine kommune für mein
land genau die richtigen sind
das ist nicht die aufgabe des deutschen
bundestages sondern dass die tour
zwischen schleswig holstein und bayern
anders gemacht und dieses spannungsfeld
verhältnis muss ich aushalten
es war keine abrechnung eine annäherung
in fragen des krisenmanagements aber war
es auch nicht morgen früh will angela
merkel im parlament eine
regierungserklärung abgeben
viele wirtschaftsverbände begrüßten die
entscheidung der kanzlerin und sprachen
von einem signal der vernunft den
unternehmen bleiben durch die absage der
ruhetage erhebliche kosten gespart
allerdings kostet dieses hin und her
eben auch vertrauen
wie wirkt es wenn die große runde in der
nacht etwas beschließt um es einen tag
später wieder zurückzunehmen
volker check hat sich umgehört
die sonne lockt dazu ein geigen
ständchen heute sind in wiesbadens
fußgängerzone mehr menschen unterwegs
als die tage zuvor
lebensmittelgeschäfte werden
gründonnerstag nun doch geöffnet sein
viele kunden haben schon gehört vom
rückzieher der kanzlerin
ich finde es gut dass es zurück genommen
wurde weil das hat nicht hand und fuß
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr irritiert
darüber dass sich die politik da jeden
tag neu entscheidet und man sich
wirklich anders orientieren kann ich
finde die jetzt richtig in der dies in
der jetzigen situation es war zu
kurzfristig gewesen das kreuz an der
glaubwürdigkeit weil entschuldigung
reicht uns ja nicht wissen seit einem
jahr in london
und es muss langsam langsam für die
menschen ein ende kommen auch die
wirtschaftsverbände sehen die kanzlerin
in der pflicht das eingeständnis einen
fehler gemacht zu haben sei ehrenwert
doch gefragt sei kein debattierclub
zwischen bund und ländern sondern eine
entschlossene führung führung heißt dann
muss man auch noch ein tisch da muss man
mal klare kante ausrufen sonst kommt man
in solchen situationen nicht voran
und das ist das problem das wir haben
mehr koordinierung im kampf gegen korona
vermisst auch der meinungsfreudige
blogger und autor sascha lobo durch das
hin und her der entscheidung sei die
bevölkerung verunsichert so gut es ist
dass frau merkel sich mal entschuldigt
hat und um verzeihung gebeten hat so
schlecht ist es dass in einer sowieso
schon labilen situation noch mehr
vertrauen kaputtgegangen ist weil
niemand mehr versteht warum wann welche
maßnahme genau vorhandenes der salto
rückwärts bei den ruhetagen zu ostern es
könnte einen weiteren vertrauensverlust
in die führungskraft der regierung
bringen
zur rücknahme der sogenannten oster ruhe
regeln und zu angela merkels
schuldeingeständnis gibt es ein zdf
spezial direkt nach uns und dann gab es
heute noch eine für deutschland
besonders wichtige zahl 240 milliarden
euro so viel neue schulden plant der
bund in diesem jahr etwa 60 milliarden
mehr als zunächst geschätzt und so viel
wie nie zuvor
der grund sind die milliardenschweren
corona hielt
aber auch die steuereinnahmen die in der
pandemie wegbrechen
david tepper berichtet
unternehmenshilfen impfstoff beschaffung
kostenlose tests die korona krise kostet
nicht nur nerven sondern auch
milliardensummen dass die ausgaben des
bundes und die neuen schulden in
pandemie zeiten immer weiter steigen
laut finanzminister und vermeintlich das
ist der wunsch wir haben es geschafft
dass wir eine bessere wirtschaftliche
entwicklung haben als ohne die maßnahmen
das ist teuer aber nichtstun wäre viel
teurer gute riffs politik ist auch gute
finanzpolitik
mit dem nachtragshaushalt erhöht sich
die neuverschuldung für 2021 um weitere
60 4 milliarden auf nun rund 240
milliarden euro für 2022 sind 81 5
milliarden euro neue schulden vorgesehen
die schuldenbremse bliebe so definitiv
im nächsten jahr ausgesetzt
immer wieder zu sagen wurms bazooka es
ist genügend geld vorhanden das weckt
natürlich begehrlichkeiten und ich
glaube als bundesfinanzminister sollte
man auch ein bisschen auf der
ausgabenbremse stehen attacke vom
koalitionspartner der finanzminister ist
schließlich auch spd-kanzlerkandidat
dass wegen der korona schuldenlast für
andere projekte künftig geld fehlt
fürchtet die opposition
wir müssen eine neue zusätzliche
investitionsoffensive machen für das
thema klimawandel auch für
digitalisierung natürlich ist das eine
gewaltige summe selbst wenn wir
irgendwann wieder normale zeiten haben
belastet das sind es muss an
sozialausgaben und einen ganz wichtigen
anderen dingen eingespart werden
sozialausgaben kürzen steuern erhöhen
oder neue schulden der streit wie die
krisenfolgen bezahlt werden wird wohl
länger bleiben als die krise selbst die
regierung will opfer von stalking besser
schützen
die entsprechende gesetzesverschärfung
sieht vor künftig auch digitales
stalking unter strafe zu stellen
der hintergrund immer öfter werden
menschen im netz und über apps
ausgeforscht eingeschüchtert und
diffamiert vor allem frauen ein weg für
lesbische paare sich einen kinderwunsch
zu erfüllen ist eine schwangerschaft per
samenspende
dabei wird bislang aber nur die
gebärende mutter in der geburtsurkunde
eingetragen
dagegen hatten zwei frauen geklagt und
jetzt vor dem oberlandesgericht celle
einen etappensieg erzielt nach der
derzeitigen regeln könnte die partnerin
die heute einjährige tochter nur als
stiefkind adoptieren verfassungswidrig
meinen die richter
der ball geht nun ans
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt nach
brüssel
da knirscht es wieder zwischen der eben
kommission und dem impfstoffhersteller
astrazeneca zur erinnerung in der eu
fehlt es immer noch an impfstoff auch
deshalb weil der konzern deutlich
weniger liefert als vereinbart
die eu will mit exportstopps
gegensteuern gleichzeitig werden in
italien 29 millionen astrazeneca dosen
entdeckt die neue rätsel aufgeben
stefan leifert das werk eines pharma
dienstleisters unweit von rom 29
millionen impfstoff dosen von
astrazeneca haben inspektoren der eu
hier gefunden von ihrer existenz war
bislang nichts bekannt in brüssel sind
sie schwer verärgert über die
undurchsichtige informationspolitik von
astrazeneca
es ist aufgabe des unternehmens zu
klären was es mit den gefundenen
impfdosen auf sich hat was wir von
unserer seite dazu sagen können ist dass
astrazeneca sehr weit davon entfernt ist
seine vertraglichen zusagen für die eu
einzuhalten
ein teil der in italien abgefüllten und
gefundenen dosen soll hier im
niederländischen werk heilix produziert
worden sein
eine eu genehmigung hat astrazeneca
hierfür noch nicht mit einem strengeren
mechanismus als bisher will die eu
sicherstellen dass sie künftig über
impfstoff exporte informiert wird und
sie notfalls stoppen kann
was uns besorgt ist der mangel an
transparenz in der art und weise wie
manche hersteller arbeiten
wir wollen alle informationen um
sicherzustellen dass alle vertraglichen
vereinbarungen auch erfüllt werden
[Musik]
am nachmittag erklärte astrazeneca ein
teil der gefundenen impfdosen seife
ärmeren nicht-eu-länder der andere teil
für europa bestimmt gewesen
die verwirrung um astrazeneca zeigt wie
dringend die eu mittel braucht sich
nicht auf der nase herumtanzen zu lassen
in dieser geschichte sieht nicht nur
astrazeneca schlecht aus sie zeigt auch
dass die eu im umgang mit den
impfstoffherstellern zu gutgläubig war
nach der vierten parlamentswahl in zwei
jahren zeichnet sich in israel eine
schwierige regierungsbildung ab bislang
sind knapp 90 prozent der stimmen
ausgezählt die partei von regierungschef
netanjahu bleibt demnach zwar stärkste
kraft um aber weiter regieren zu können
müsste sie wohl eine koalition unter
anderem mit ultra orthodoxen und ultra
nationalistischen parteien eingehen
die auszählung der stimmen läuft noch
bis übermorgen
der suez kanal ist eine der wichtigsten
handelswege zwischen europa und asien
derzeit aber blockiert in der nacht ist
eines der größten containerschiffe der
welt auf grund gelaufen
seitdem steht der 400 meter riese quer
schlepper und bagger versuchen ihn
wieder flott zu machen derweil stauen
sich in beiden richtungen warten der
schiffe grund für die havarie war
offenbar ein sandsturm und jetzt fußball
norbert heute startet die
europameisterschaft hat die der u 21
unter trifft die dfb nachwuchs elf heute
abend auf mit gastgeber ungarn der
gegner schwer einzuschätzen das team von
stefan kunz kaum eingespielt kein
einfacher start in eine in vielfacher
hinsicht besondere em besondere zeiten
besonderes team das em motto der dfb elf
drei gruppenspiele in sieben tagen die
ko runde dann ab ende mai ein incidence
wert von beinahe 600 beim co-gastgeber
wir haben halt durch unser hygiene
konzept bewiesen dass wir gesund durch
die sache kommen ich hoffe dass das dass
das nicht konnten konfiguriert wird die
nächsten tage aber und dadurch dieses
mindestmaß an an freude und spaß am
fußball zu erhalten und gerade für die
jungen spieler
das ist dann schon wert die u21 will
sich gegen ungarn auf das eigene spiel
konzentrieren und bei der em darauf
neulinge wie den dortmunder yusuf amoco
zu integrieren
im champions league viertelfinale der
frauen hat wolfsburg am nachmittag das
hinspiel gegen chelsea in budapest
verloren die engländerin siebten mit 2
zu 1 ja und morgen abend in duisburg
deutschland gegen island das erste der
drei wm quali spiele der dfb-elf die
ansage des bundestrainers ist klar
drei siege sind pflicht bei seiner
letzten etappe als bundestrainer villa
spielfreude sehen und aufbruchstimmung
erzeugen
am frühen abend waren alle verbliebenen
23 akteure dabei nach dem 0 6 gegen
spanien ende letzten jahres nimmt er
sein team nun in die pflicht
sehr schlecht aus diesem jahr aus sind
und mit einer großen enttäuschung auch
mit einer wut erwarte ich natürlich
jetzt eine reaktion von der mannschaft
nach dem ausfall von toni kroos werden
im zentralen mittelfeld josua kimmig und
leon goretzka spielen davor in der
offensiveren rolle der momentan
überragende ilkay gündogan beim ersten
wm-casting im neuen jahr wollen sich
alle von ihrer besten seite zeigen das
was am sport schöne beispiele jetzt noch
was zu respekt und dankbarkeit es geht
um dieses bild des street art künstlers
banksy ein junger und die superheldin
seiner wahl eine krankenschwester besser
als batman besser als beide männer
banksy der seine identität geheim hält
hatte das werk einem krankenhaus in
southampton geschenkt nun wurde es
versteigert für fast 20 millionen euro
zugunsten britischer klicken und hier
winken jetzt auch millionen beim lotto
die gewinnzahlen lauten 4 11 14 23 24 48
und die superzahl 4 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157
das wetter bringt regen aber auch sonne
wo wann was erzählt gleich aus dem
termin im heute journal um kurz nach 10
stellt sich vizekanzler scholz den
fragen von marietta slomka
hier übernimmt morgen christian sievers
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihn
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
macht es möglich viel sonnenschein gab
es heute im westen deutschlands und auch
nach süden viele wolken in den östlichen
landesteilen
diese wirkung zog aber dann auch im
tagesverlauf ab wir schauen auf die
großwetterlage unter erreichen uns neue
werk mit dieser kaltfront und schauer
sind inklusive allerdings lockert es
dahinter schon wieder auf die kommende
nacht die bringt uns viele wolken im
norden ansonsten klart es auf nach süden
und hier an den alpen wird am kältesten
seien mit minus 4 grad ansonsten am
mildesten ganz im nordwesten mit
temperaturen um plus sechs grad
morgen gibt es dann viel sonne im süden
deutschland und harmlose bewölkung
ansonsten ziehen die schauer der
kaltfront auf unter einem tagesverlauf
nach osten hin ab und die temperaturen
erreichen werte bis 17 grad im südwesten
und 10 grad in schleswig-holstein das
ist die temperaturspanne und die
nächsten tage am freitag im süden
trocken teils sonnig bei 12 bis 18 grad
aber im norden gibt es schauer am
samstag ändert sich wird das wetter es
wird stürmisch teils mit graupel
gewittern
ja und temperaturen bis 12 grad ein
schöner abend